the opening pages of a screenplay
important or cliche
well cliches work for a reason
but you know if you do it well
then it works
so you mean what do you mean what's the
context of the opening how important are
they are people really tossing something
in a pile in a slush pile
based on
yeah they do but it's like if you can
grab like you have it has to play
professional it has to read professional
and it also has to have something
happening in the beginning you know and
it can't be just exposition people
sitting around talking um
yeah it is and you know i've even see
here's another thing people don't know
is that producers will look at what the
genre is and see the page count at the
end
and it's like if you've written a script
that's like 150 pages they're like this
person doesn't know what they're doing
because no one should write a script
over 115 pages unless you're quint
tarantino or like paul thomas anderson
and if it's like a
horror movie it's 140 pages are going to
be like what that is going on because
you know
how many pages they're all i mean if you
look at most professional scripts
they're always
studio scripts or anything they're 105
to like 112 pages like clockwork horror
movies a little bit less you know
they're like 98 to like 104 but you know
so they see so many scripts and they
know they can you know and you've got to
keep in mind your time you're competing
for their time against professional
scripts they're getting so it's got to
be you know really awesome and it's got
to be bombastic in the beginning not not
you're blowing stuff up but you have to
grab them somehow do something somehow
you know that really shows like
you know oh wow i haven't seen that
before wow that's interesting you know
have somebody you know have adrenaline
needles jammed in their heart on the
first like you know
first line you know wakes up where am i
you do something you know and that
doesn't necessarily have to be how the
story starts but you have to figure out
a way to like make it work
and have the beginning be something
that's really really interesting
how much time do you spend on the first
page of a screenplay
not much
maybe like 10 minutes
maybe five it just depends on the on the
flow but a lot of times when i first
start something i'll just be like this
and i kind of know because i've thought
about the beats
of what i want to happen and then i'll
go back and rework it
you know so it's like i'm more concerned
not necessarily with all the dialogue
you know line for line but more what the
scene is saying like what's the
beginning middle and end of the scene
and what's trying to get across and then
go back and finesse all that stuff and
two now i
i do a new system now where i don't
write any description while i'm writing
i'll just say describe office
you know and then go back and do that at
the end because it doesn't have anything
to do really with
the story it slows you down yeah
yeah
would paneling you know file yeah
exactly and go back and do all that one
time at the end
interesting so you put in like a little
space holder yeah explain city explain
the car you know describe here
now if it's really important the story
maybe i'll put it in but if it's just
you know like if the spy movie it's like
and you got to describe paris you know
as the sunrise comes up i'll do that
later just put established pairs they
just keep going because that's not you
know that's easy to do
how do you write a screenplay in two
weeks
i think a bigger question how do you
write screenplay in two days because
i've done that um
it's actually like the time
writing is differs but it's like how
much have you thought about it you know
because
there's times i think i said earlier
i'll think about something for two three
weeks before i even touch the keyboard
about the story and run a lot of it in
my head
and if i get a big chunk of it it's like
i could just write 20 30 pages in a day
but i've thought about it it's not just
i'm like looking at the blank page i'm
not one of those people stares at the
computer i'll go for walks
you know i'll get coffee do whatever you
know ride a bike that's where i get all
my ideas
and for some reason driving um
but it's like you almost get in this
zone of like thinking about things and
sometimes when i'm stuck i'll go for a
walk i can come back and write like five
or six scenes because i just saw it on
my head
so
yeah that's that's the process i mean
there's one screenplay i wrote in two
two days because i forgot when i was
supposed to deliver it
and this is when i was first writing
and then it became
you know it was supposed to be a half
million dollar little action movie that
became a 10 million dollar film you know
and i wrote in two days
so but there were a lot of parameters
set on that job it had to be one
location
don't want to change wardrobe the actor
can't talk too much because he's an mma
fighter like there are all these things
and i just was like you know what i kept
putting it off because i really didn't
want to do it i got paid and i was i
wrote in a weekend
and then it became a 10 million dollar
film they didn't really use the script
it kept changing and changing but it you
know so it you never know
strange things happen in this business
what's an example of lingering too long
on a film project um
that's a good question it's you mean if
you write a script and you keep trying
to get it made and getting it made and
it's not working
um
yeah i don't know it depends on who
you're talking to if you you don't have
any contacts and you're slowly building
up you know who you know and getting
people to read it you know it could take
a process of years but if you had a
project that you gave to your agent your
manager and you had some producers read
and everybody was kind of like not
really
jiving with it i would say you know
put it away and write something out so
it kind of depends on where you're at
you know it's like if if you've got a
great script but you don't have access
to get the proper people to read it for
a couple years it's going to take a
couple years
so
your instinct should tell you everything
though people are really responding the
right people if you can get some right
people to really read it you know if you
do one of those um
you know coverage things or something
and they give you 50 pages of coverage
maybe you're in trouble you know but
so so that's i don't really know the
answer to that but i think you just have
to use your instinct on what's working
what's not
sometimes you write a script and you
know it's not good enough how do you
know
again just instinct it's like you know
i've worked on things where it's like
it feels
great but it doesn't feel amazing like
it's it feels like it's almost there or
maybe the first 60 pages are seem really
amazing but the the third act doesn't
work
so you just have to know i wrote a high
script recently i was working on you
know i got inspired and quickly wrote
this high school i think the first 60
pages are great but the the third act is
horrible which usually not something
that happens it's not horrible but it
doesn't keep up with the rest of the
film and
i'm not getting any inspiration to
to come up with the third act so i just
put it away for now you know maybe i'll
revisit in six months or three months or
two years from now
but you just kind of have to know when
things are working and when they're not
you know are you banging your head
against the wall
that's not good
you know if there's something that you
feel is like
you can't crack the nut all the way
through or figure it out you should
maybe think about something or put it
down for a while sometimes you can put
something down and come back to it you
know there's a lot of people i know a
lot of directors i know who worked on
things for years they put things away
and they come back to them and they'll
be like hey
wow this is pretty cool but they have a
fresh perspective on it all
was there a project that taught you how
important your instinct was
maybe you didn't pay attention to it
before when it came to writing
yeah i think it happened i think the the
movie rage that we did the screenplay
was called tokarev originally um
i love this movie this british film
called the long good friday which uh
um has bob hoskins in it it's from the
early 80s and i was like i want to do
something like that and i kept thinking
and then i mentioned to a few people and
they didn't know the movie or they just
were like yeah whatever and i was like
no this could make a really cool
thing you know
tonally it was that kind of movie the
story's completely different but it kind
of had the same tone
and
that was when we were writing a lot of
horror things just doing horror shawn
and i were just doing horror that's all
i was working on and i was like no this
thriller is a cool thriller and it's got
a lot of things
that are going for it and
i wrote like half the script in like one
day i just kept thinking about it then i
sent over sean he did some work on and
we finished it and
it got amazing response and it was one
of those times where i was like
i think
i need to move from horror into thriller
stuff and this is like a really cool
idea and it worked you know
and everybody loved the script and it
got made and
did really well for us so because of
that you realized okay i can trust
myself
yeah yeah
same thing happened with writing a pilot
too for that we sold the abc it's like
we never worked in tv and then one day i
was like we should write a pilot we
decided to write a pilot and how to find
copies of pilots to even know the
structure
and i think we call our manager it's
like hey can you send us some pilots and
wrote a pilot without ever knowing
anything about pilots and there was a
bidding war between abc and nbc for when
we sold it didn't get made but
it was like another one of those times
where it's like
i don't know never worked on tv but it
feels like maybe we should do some tv so
yeah just follow a lot of instinct stuff
works don't know why
you